I've decided something I'm gonna do
movies again I'm gonna do movies again
and I'm gonna do TV again and there's
nothing anybody can do about it and I'm
gonna [__] be on the [__] and I'm
going to be acting so good and you're
gonna be blown away Blown Away dude
blown away I'm gonna play a guy who
stutters I'm gonna play a Korean guy no
makeup I'm gonna be playing I'm gonna
you think I'm not gonna play a twink I'm
gonna play a twink dude and I'm gonna
guess what I'm gonna do no research and
I'm just gonna come in blow the doors
off not get nominated for [__] because
of we know the woke environment but
you're gonna know secretly that your boy
needs to be nominated dude I'm gonna
play a woman a woman not a trans woman a
woman
I know trans women are women
but a woman from just like you know what
I'm talking about like Ben Shapiro would
be like that's a one that's a woman like
that that kind of woman
that's what I'm gonna play dude
trans women are women or whatever you
know I don't know dude I don't care I
don't know
like somebody people are like yeah but
don't stay silent or it's perpetuating
that nah dude guess what zip that's it
unzip because I got to do the podcast
but zip do it
like I'm not I don't I don't care about
all the issues yeah I don't give a [__]
oh but that's your privilege okay
how about that dude and you know what
people are doing right now they're
listening to me they're going like this
[__] yeah you're right dude I'm gonna I
feel that way but you can't say it
because you got a regular job but I can
because I'm on patreon and I can because
I do stand up previously on the governor
starring crystalia that's gonna be me on
ABC dude when I come back and just
[__] acting as a woman Governor not
somebody who's trans
Ben Shapiro's gonna be like oh it's
kristalia I thought it was a woman he's
really good previously on the governor
hey guys you really need to pass that
bill
previously on the governor I love you
but it's different because God there's
so many judges previously on the
governor
no I know but God move away move
lobbyists I'm trying to get to my
meeting
[Laughter]
ah dude move out of the way lobbyists
nobody grows up and says one day I'm
gonna be a lobbyist
it's never happened
it's happened more where people say when
I grow up I'm gonna be a crack [__]
previously on crack [__] starring
crystalia I really no you have to you
you have to use one I'm scared of St
previously on crack [__] starring
crystalia it's 25
crystalia I'll do it for 12. previously
on crack [__] starring crystalia freeze
oh no not again
at least I'm not a lobbyists
[Music]